[Music]
all right in rest in peace legend news
oh no oh I know I know I know
you do yeah how my life man there's a
legend that just a legend rest in peace
submitted by me so hungry Oh me so
hungry I know that song what he's
already okay the world is mourning after
Hugh Hefner passes away at age 91 you
what the [ __ ] I was gonna get a reaction
or something know about the legend no
cuz I didn't know he was considered a
legend what I mean I know he is a late
boy yeah I know about that I know about
all of that but like for me legend it's
like I usually think of it as someone
that's like like Hercules like
skill-based he's a writer he's a writer
and change the game like crazy he's a
he's maybe my definition of legend is
skewed then consider like I would
consider like Trump a legend would not
know for me I thought legend was
skill-based like he's a fighter or he's
a musician or a singer or like that
either writer if you actually read up on
Hugh Hefner in the 50s and the 60s he
was a prolific writer in my crotch I
started the magazine and built into the
the company it is now it's it's pretty
amazing magazine mobile and the fact
that it was back then I think that's a
key thing cause it was so much more you
know not so open back then you know I
think you know things were a lot more
with that word call taboo this is
conservative yeah it's a lot more
conservative he was able to build
something in that time of that caliber I
think now it's pretty at a time where
like girls were pretty much wetsuits to
go swimming above all it's a torture
okay so Hugh Marsden Hefner was born in
1926 goddamn he started a playboy in
1953 oh yeah that was a living fossil
yeah a lot of people were really bummed
out the legend but there were also a lot
of people that were like good whoa be
gone because it's mainly like the
feminist
early you know people that are just
against what he did with playboy and
everything so it's like a snap when I
really fully have but there's still some
people that they were didn't really mind
so they're condemning him after death
the way people condemned like Saddam
Hussein and and Osama bin Laden like
like that but there's probably people
that just really despise him though yeah
because how he made a profit by
objectifying women and stuff not like
that but there was a lot of rumors and
stories from previous claim eight that
he was controlling and abusive and
things like that so that's why that
group of people were just they didn't
mind that in the past but talking about
the majority a lot of people were really
bad at his passing so I'll show you guys
some photos there's Hugh hiss oh he was
a captain of a ship he always looked oh
he always had the Hat and like the red
or the burgundy road pipe yeah the fight
he was always in a row yeah like a
smoker robe or something ears with his
bunnies yeah and so like he he had his
magazine at one point he had a club in
Chicago and so here remember how he did
the reality TV show girls next door oh
yeah this is one of the girls Bridget or
Bridget so she tweeted out when he
passed so sad but forever grateful for
all the wonderful memories and amazing
experiences
hashtag recipes have hashtag playboy
broken heart emoji how do you stay a sex
symbol till your 90s maybe it's his
money
maybe I didn't his mind is like how
powerful he is and like what he was able
to do I've never heard him talk or doing
it up he's never around him no not like
a person like in interviews like I've
never heard an interview with him or
anything there are they have documentary
yeah he's speaking he has a world
Guinness record for the largest
scrapbooking collection what he has
enough content to go like 30 years of
like watching his who's shaped like his
whole life yeah yeah he even hired a
person to specifically do that like
everything that his entire life was
about its document wait he so he vlog
his entire
but not but not in vlogging but could
use video to call me if you follow
playboy they post like scrapbook Monday
or whatever and you can see all the old
photos that they post every week pretty
tight like seeing so many years is like
how cool was he ever met him he was
married three times three times yeah I
came tweeted out recipes to the
legendary Hugh Hefner I'm so honored to
have been a part of the Playboy team you
will be grateful you will be greatly
missed love you have xoxo she put a
bunch of her playboy pictures up and I
saw her vagina
what's a top vagina like the this part
like just the facing it yeah you'd have
a unibrow knit that this part yeah she
didn't say I was like oh cool I got to
see it oh I mean oh I don't know I don't
want to see her yeah and then Jenny
McCartney McCarthy sorry she brought
recipes thank you for being a
revolutionary and changing so many
people's lives especially mine I hope I
made you proud you made so many stars on
a lie that's so cool he was also a civil
rights activist so Reverend Jesse
Jackson he tweeted out Hugh Hefner was a
strong supporter of the civil rights
movement we shall never forget him may
he rest in peace
he's a handsome man handsome old man had
some old man I don't know what he looks
like young yeah during the time of I
think when he made it it was like what
it was still culturally segregation
thankfully it was segregation but then
at the Playboy Mansion though it was a
very multicultural place yeah he was the
one to feature a black woman on the
cover when no other magazine would he
was a strong supporter of Martin Luther
King jr. and yeah
however involved in that so let's talk
you see my whole life is he like the kid
epitome of a beatnik you think all the
poetry people's yeah like the the
hippies of the 50s like you grew up like
super conservative and the whole reason
why he turned into the Hathaway on new
was because in high school he got
rejected by a girl that he really liked
and then he just completely changed like
his entire way of thinking and he even
like drew a comic of himself of like
what he wanted to see his future be like
and then ended up being similar to what
he ended up being oh cool
so he's just saying like the reason why
he started all this is because he grew
up really conservative and he wanted to
break out of that I mean I like the
whole like he wanted to be more diverse
and Falzone yeah you lived a very full
life and someone created this little
cartoon
it says Kevin are you kidding I just
left heaven yeah been there have you
guys ever been to the Playboy Mansion I
didn't get there how do you get invited
or yeah is it an invite-only huh not
anymore
oh it's not know his mansion was sold to
some super rich dude and so they're
thinking that they might convert it into
a hotel but we don't know yet people we
know like when like a Rico goes every
year for like Halloween parties Nicky -
she has a photo with her oh yeah she was
actually featured in something with
Playboy's I think for guys if you're not
someone super special you just have to
pay like ass loads of money to get in
I'm not getting in the only note the
only thing I know about for guys is um I
hear Michael Bay walks around with the
shirt unbuttoned showing his six-pack as
he walks around imagine all day long
that could be yeah I mean if you worked
hard for it you should show it off yeah
Michael Bay has a six-pack yeah like a
director with the six-pack and he just
walked around although does he wear like
a cholo where it's just unbuttoned here
and it's just no he wears him Miami
style I mean the whole thing is just on
but like the Will Smith look from bad
boys running shirt with the open yeah
like an Abercrombie model or some [ __ ]
yeah that's interesting that with
Michael based trademark what do you call
it the mullet haircut there has I think
I'd wear just underwear
a t-shirt at the Playboy Mansion what
kind of underwear just like speedos or
something that's what I pictured too so
all you hits like a little baby you
walking around with just a t-shirt then
legs just just like that do the opposite
you know you got to change the game it's
true yeah that'd be memorable it's nice
to think like ten years ago maybe even
like closer to 20 like a lot of girls
would just drive I shouldn't say a lot
but there were girls that I knew that
we're striving to get into like anything
playable like playboy was like this [ __ ]
like they would get like tattoos of the
bunny and stuff I'm like what the [ __ ]
like the Brad was huge
thank you Instagram killed playboy huh
kind of well I think just social media
killed anything print
yeah well magazine they're no longer
gonna be printing anymore they just kept
it around as long as Hef was like oh oh
my god
didn't his son like take it over but
then I guess they they were just like
we're not making money on this at all so
they're like we're just gonna keep it to
him a passion project exactly yeah
that's really sad yeah it makes sense
because if you think about like back in
a day the only access to to do editorial
plus yeah pictures it's just playboy or
hustler those were the two things
hustler if you wanted to watch the
hardcore [ __ ] and then like porn came
out on VHS yeah the hustler dude he
wanted to buy the Playboy Mansion he
wanted to create it into the hustler
mansion but then the other rich guys got
that single playboys classy yeah you
can't do that to playboy hustlers like
girls on meth and Bill do anything for
meth [ __ ] I was kidding yeah but it's
kind of like the trash it's like
hustlers the dark alley it's like the
Walmart yeah and then and in Playboy's
like the high-class escort clique though
it's this problem it's the stress yeah
once Walmart the other ones like on the
Playboy pictures you barely see a little
bit of the vagina and then hustler as
you spread the curtains oh yeah and
there's like slime you lookin to some
there's just photos of them [ __ ]
Norway yeah girls [ __ ] and there's
photos of it just oh [ __ ] [ __ ] and so
you guys see penis is like Florida yeah
straight both photography but one during
the first you know big companies to
really put it into a publication like
that and have a really big you know
building on and it's it's called like
Flint publications or whatever was it
that the most interesting you've ever
heard and your whole entire life I don't
even know what you guys just talked
about but anyways please subscribe for
more random videos more funny content
and more hahaha poopoo in your pants
stuff go ahead subscribe and for more
videos right there